(upbeat music)
- Science can make a big difference,
anywhere from just a simple reaction
to a big experiment.
If you just find the right application,
science can save the world.
My name is Gitanjali Rao,
and I'm 12 years old.
I'm a scientist.
I invented a device called Tethys
that detects leads in water faster
than any other current
techniques out there today.
I was appalled by the number of people
affected by lead in water
during the Flint water crisis.
I wanted to do something to change this
for the residents of Flint
and places like Flint all over the world.
My device includes a core device
and a disposable cartridge
with the carbon in a tube sensor.
You dip this disposable
cartridge into the water
you wanna test.
You pull out your phone, open
up the Tethis application,
and connect over Bluetooth
to get the results
of safe, slightly
contaminated, or critical
of lead levels in your water.
My advice to other kids
who wanna save the world
is do not be afraid to try.
I failed like four or five times,
but I got back into the lab,
did it again, and then it
was like the a-ha moment
when everything kind of
started coming together
and, you know, the device is born.
I think that science allows me
to look at different approaches
to solve real-world
problems out there today.
It's important to take
other people's problems
and make something to help them with it,
mainly because we're all one big community,
and it's our duty to help other people.